what's going on a lot of stuff is going
on you know we had you know I got to go
on Joe Rogan this week we went on Joe
Rogan and Joe Rogan's you know it's I
was nervous first of all you know I was
nervous because I look up to Joe so much
you know and for some reason with me I
think when I look up to somebody it for
some reason it makes me kind of nervous
you know I guess well you wanna I don't
know it's like when you're hanging out
you know what it feels like to me a
little bit it's like you're hanging out
with your big brother and his friends
and you're like you wanna you know
you're just I don't know I was just
nervous but it was it was wild man and
right off the bat Joe Joe start stalking
me and I love Joe you know I'm extremely
grateful to him you know he's done a lot
of nice things small things that were
really nice for me like out of AA like
he would just see me do comedy and I've
said this before but he would just drop
me a text a couple days later the next
day and just say hey man you had a
really good set you know and uh and that
kind of stuff like you don't realize
sometimes like somebody that you had my
or like you know telling you something
pop sharing something positive
supporting what you do you don't realize
how much that means to that person and
he doesn't you know I don't think he you
know he doesn't probably realize it but
it's like I would get those texts and
I'm like wow man you know it's like your
big bro it's like I don't know it's just
like you know it's like impressing your
brother impressing I don't know you know
and that kind of stuff really just res
has resonated with me over the years
he's done that and Joey Diaz does that
as well he'll call you but but Joe would
do that sometimes and just hit me up and
say hey man you were really funny last
night and you know coming from you know
my life when all I wanted to do probably
was you know make make people I admired
you know make them feel like or make
them feel like I was part of like I was
okay you know maybe some of that goes
back to like father and brother you know
not being present growing up and all of
that but you know just when you have a
you know when you have a male figure in
it you know just that support support
that's really what it is Joe's been so
supportive and so you know anyway but
you know I was excited to be in there
and I was excited to get to hang out
with him because he thinks like wild you
know he's like he thinks like he's got
you know it's like I don't I think he
has more than one brain in his head you
know Joe Rogan might have five or six
brains in there and one of the brains is
probably a rat you know and then he's
but he might have other brains orbiting
around brains you know he might have one
brains it's you know he might have
brains in the distance you know cooking
elk I mean he's got you know he just he
continues to kind of like expand his way
of thinking and so right in the
beginning he was talking about infinite
and infinite uh if there were infinite
universes and if there were more than
just one of you and I couldn't even I
was so nervous kind of I was just
couldn't even think really that good and
but then now I'm thinking after that I
texted him the next day and I was like
manna
I'm obsessed now with wondering if there
are infinite universes so many so this
is what he was saying there's so many
infinite universes that if you there
would be a possibility for you to meet
your exact self like you know say the
two universes get close enough to each
other somehow in orbits or whatever and
then you you know there's you know
programs you're both astronauts or
something you meet like if you were to
able to meet your exact self think about
that if you were able to meet your exact
self
and I was just like I left there
thinking would I like myself like
if Ike I find met me like what I like me
what would I do what would I think what
I think I was neat you know what I think
I was tall what I think that I was
handsome you know what I think that I I
mean would I know if I were able to look
into my own eyes would I be able to like
see my truth set like another like
another dimension you know especially
since most of my life you know
especially growing up like I didn't have
any a lot of self-worth so I was most of
my self-worth would come from what other
people thought of me you know there was
no you know the there was nothing inside
of me so everything that I knew I had to
get from the outside and so I was so
hyper aware of what other people were
constantly thinking because I needed to
be because I needed that next second and
that next minute and that next you know
just to know I knew I was monitoring how
I was and if I was okay through moment
to moment interaction with others and
what they would give me back that's how
I feel about myself I was thinking like
if I based my feelings off of what other
people thought of me and I saw myself
would I then like looking into my own
eyes would I be able to you know just
come full circle with with what self
worth means and what it you know and and
just I get to another plateau in
thinking about that but it was just
fascinated me I left out of there
thinking like what the [ __ ] I never
thought about running into myself what I
think I had bad breath you know what I
think I had like a longneck or a regular
neck or um you know what kind of us you
know a 4 out of 10 kind of a mid-range
lower you know lower mid-range neck
medium rare because I've all you know
I've had you know my don't have a super
long neck and I don't think a lot of
people in my family we're not real look
around us some people have a long neck
you know when you see those people
they're looking for stuff and they can
you know look behind the sofa easier and
they don't lose their wallet probably as
much because they
you know they got that extra two inches
to look then the gays you know they
could see fruit easier if their region
if they're looking for fruits but when
you have that limited neck man you kind
of you know you're stuck on your own
little bitty you know it's not really a
hilltop you just kind of stuck on you
know you kind of just hanging out on
your own cliffside you can't do a lot
when you got that limited kind of that
limited net and I come from a long line
of people with limited necks but yeah I
was just wondering if you saw yourself
and you looked in your own eyes would
you I don't know what we thought I mean
would your just whole world explode like
would you just know everything but I
like myself but I like just blew my mind
if there were infinite universes and it
just blew my mind man so I left out of
there I think with a little bit more
thinking you know and I think that
that's kind of what Joe Rogan does for
me is he makes me think a little bit
more and he makes me think sometimes I'm
like uncomfortable things you know he
makes me think outside of like the
confines of the comfortable confines of
things that you know these these
templates that I was raised in or raised
around or just that I saw you know it's
kind of like when you see remember when
you got that you got them colors when
you were a child and your mother took
you to the color shop and you got that
aid box you got that box eight hitters
you know that were that you know just
that little [ __ ] that ROYGBIV fiasco
you know you got that little eight pack
that 8-ball you know you got that eight
ball and suddenly some dude shows up
with that six staff follow-up box and
your [ __ ] dick blew out of your ears
remember that dude I remember my nuts
traveled up my body and looked out of my
I hold because I was just
I was just shook by the fact that some
man suddenly had 56 more colors than I
had some boy I mean not a man they
didn't have any men in our class you
know in disguise or anything but that
some boy and it blew my mind and
suddenly you were doing different
pictures and you were thinking different
things and you you're like [ __ ] magenta
I'm out here on magenta and then and
then and then everything changed because
then I would see a you know maybe I
would see a somebody's shirt or hat or a
you know I would see a woman's head at
church you mean like oh that's a magenta
hat and suddenly you know you have more
elements to put out into your template
to put out into your world and that's
kind of I think you know that's kind of
what I left out of Joe Rogan's podcast
thinking I left out of there actually
just thinking you know he makes me think
and I think he makes a lot of you know
young men and women think you know he's
kind of this dope-ass outer space male
you know marine kind of not he's just
everything I don't know what he is man
it's almost like if you took a whole
timeline of existence and just took it
like that and put it all in no one
person it's like the past and you know
in the future and everything and he's
probably got moons
I bet dude I bet he has moons going
around him I bet there's a moon way off
in the distance that we don't even know
about that's just that you know just
that Rogan that Rogen moon but it was an
honor man it's an honor to go in there
you know it's just an honor you know
like I don't know it made and it made me
fit you know I just felt like accepted
you know like he made me feel accepted
which for me is like a really big thing
you know like um you know like I think a
lot of my life I don't feel that way um
and so to go in and and I don't I don't
even think these are things that he's
you know outwardly doing like on purpose
I think someone's just his nature
uh you know I think in some ways he's
like a little bit of like that big
brother that like you know you know I
had my brother but my brother you know
didn't live with us and like you know
and he you know and he's had some you
know he's had some tough times even
though I'll you know I really love my
brother and I'm you know I don't think
I've ever been prouder of anybody in my
whole life than him but uh anyway damn
boy
this [ __ ] got me glee can out my
eyeballs dude you know I'm saying I'm
[ __ ] making salt water dude I'm a
damn I'm like a sixth grade science
experiments it but yeah I don't know he
just made me feel accepted and just you
know I don't know but I'm just grateful
man you know I'm just grateful to be in
an environment where I feel inspired you
know I get to go on some of these other
podcast fighter in the kid and those
guys make me laugh man you know this and
they make you laugh I know it because I
get out on the road and I see these you
know I see a fighter and the kid
listeners and I'm a fighter in the kid
listener so I know it's like there's
just this wild we're part of their party
you know we're part of their party and I
guess I'm just grateful to Bisbee you
know just just I guess I don't know I'm
just grateful I guess to feel accepted
some and maybe you know that shouldn't
matter to me and I don't I don't know if
it matters it's not a thing like it like
I walk around thinking like those guys
didn't accept me ever but
I don't know I just and it's just
something that I feel so anyway man
there was a lot more to spend in time
over at Rogen's and you know the
conversation was kind of all over and he
thinks it's so fast and it's hard for me
too you know he's got that he's got
Lance Armstrong in his blood so that
dudes out there he's in outer space he's
walking on the moon
you know he's juggling he's playing
saxophone I mean he's got all kinds of
things and going on inside of him and
but it was fun man it was exciting and
it was fun and so if you wonder what
it's like to kind of go in because I get
a lot of messages I could deal what's it
like to go to Joe Rogan's and you know
is it like is it underground somebody
asks me if it's underground like it's a
bunker and that made me laugh so hard
man no actually it's in a blimp it is we
leave the earth and we go out there and
Eddie Bravo's the driver and we just
travel around and so that way you get a
first-hand look at some of the things
that um you know some of the you know
some of the things that Joe is talking
about but yeah man I just had a blast
and I and I know that a lot of you know
people that are you know fans of mine
and friends of mine and just being able
to listen to me talk to somebody that we
all admire like Joe I just know it was
fun for a lot of us so I was just glad
to be I was just glad to be there
Wow you know it's crazy as my sister
can't even read but what does it have to
do with us right now hope you enjoyed
that video and you can watch another and
you can watch this one you can watch
this one different options different
choices some guy just brings you one
option not this guy
two options watch one this one guess
what